des morceaux de bois et pierre de la
terre ou encore du sable
c'est à partir de ces matériaux naturels
que les classes de la circonscription de
saint leu et trois bassins ont créé
leurs oeuvres pour le projet land art
exposé au jardin botanique de la réunion
cette année oui on s'est inspiré de
trois chansons du patrimoine local
heures notamment deux chansons du groupe
graines semées s'appelait un bohème et
papillon et puis la troisième chanson
c'était le cas ce qu'avait le tourment
de la jac fredonner le principe donc ce
que c'est éphémère
voilà cette année donc il n'y a pas eu
des oeuvres créées dans le jardin même
donc les oeuvres ont été créées soit
dans les écoles soit sur site on voit
certaines classes sont allés en forêt
d'autres sur le bord de mer et avec ce
qu'ils ont tous récupéré ont créé et
réalisé puis exposées directement sur
les sites extérieurs les oeuvres
subissent les dégâts du temps mais
perdureront à travers des photographies
c'est aussi leur permettre avec
l'éducation plus reçoivent enfin la
formation que reçoivent les enseignants
de s'approprier aussi d'autres lieux
parce que quelque part au jardin ça
devient presque facile pour certains
donc maintenant c'est les inviter à les
découvrir d'autres sites est allé les
investir avec de la création donc c'est
un même si ça se passe par ici pour nous
c'est bien que y ait cette démarche
d'ouverture est donc cette fois ci on
accueille donc l'exposition des oeuvres
réalisées sur la plage dans la forêt
d'étang salé dans les écoles
l'exposition photographique land art sur
le thème la nature source de création a
débuté le 6 avril au jardin botanique
les élèves ont pu y découvrir leurs
oeuvres ainsi que les travaux des
différentes écoles ils ont pu visiter le
jardin botanique et assister à une
animation proposée par un médiateur de
mascarin afin de créer une continuité
entre la création et la découverte au
niveau du jardin si vous voulez pour
nous c'est très important d'avoir cette
approche sensorielle et le maillet si
vous voulez sciences et arts voilà c'est
quelque chose qui touche peut-être plus
facilement le coeur aussi
en même temps on apprend mais on apprend
avec avec plaisir un mélange de science
naturelle d'arts plastiques et aussi
d'histoire des arts
ce projet a pour objectif de
sensibiliser les élèves quant à la
protection de leur environnement
mais aussi à réfléchir sur la relation
entre l'homme et la nature
ils prennent conscience que l'oeuvre
peut être éphémère mais devient immortel
grâce à une autre expression artistique
la photographie